hi i'm radu i work at sema text
and
there i do search consulting mostly on
elasticsearch i also work on this
logging product that's why i'm a
vlogging geek
it's also built on top of elasticsearch
um and i uh also co-authoring
elasticsearch in action and before i
start i just want to ask you uh like how
many of you are already using
elasticsearch or have played with it or
something like that can i get
oh so quite
okay
how about lucine or solar
okay
and other search technologies i don't
know
okay
okay so i guess a lot will sound
familiar
um
so
not sure how many of you have brought
laptops or want to use them but later i
want to give a bit of a demo on how to
do some stuff with elasticsearch and if
you want to join me uh
it would be great
um
at one point i will just
have more notes in my class than i'd
like to invite you to join
so if you want to do that just go to
elasticsearch.org
download
and
get the
get that archive and unpack it and we'll
pick it up from there
if you don't want to do that the all the
comments that are run here will be
you can find them on github
we'll have the presentation up and
everything so
can you still hear me on the back
okay
because i'm like yeah
so um
right so just just to search to start
with uh with a bit of an overview um
this is how i see elasticsearch in my
mind there's if you have a bunch of data
you can set it send it over you can
elasticsearch can store it for you you
can it can index it for you and then you
can
do search and you can also do all sorts
of statistics through facets
to index some data you
will probably use the rest api that
means your documents will get it will be
json documents and you'll send them over
to http
um
search will go pretty much the same way
you will send your research requests in
json
over http you'll get back the
the results in json
and there are quite a lot of features
around search as you'd expect it's a
search engine
i'll just
give you a few examples so as you'd
expect from a search engine
you will get
results sorted by relevance if you want
to
you can get auto-complete
and other uh you know goodies like did
you mean or stuff like that so you don't
have to
figure out in advance what you need to
search for
and
the really cool thing about it is
that it scales by default so if you just
start indexing data without configuring
anything
uh by default your first index will be
broken into five shards
and uh it will also try to replicate
those five shards once but if you just
start with one note that won't happen
because it doesn't make any sense
but if you add another node
um
they typically uh see each other through
a built-in mechanism which is called
discovery for example by default there's
multicast discovery so if you just start
to two nodes in the same network they
will see each other they will form a
cluster and once that happens the first
thing that is done is the five replicas
that are just sitting there will get
allocated to your second node so
basically you'll have two copies of your
data you have more availability
and also your searches will round robin
between the primary shards and the so
you'll get more
concurrent searches
and then you can add some more nodes and
again that will join the cluster and
what happens from this point on is that
those shards and replicas will get
balanced across your cluster so
automatically some of the shards from
the first two nodes will get migrated to
the third one
and it can also scale back
like if you if a node goes down or if
you just take it down the first thing
that happens automatically some of the
replicas will get
uh promoted to primary shards so you can
continue indexing
and then uh
additional replicas will get created so
that you you're back to uh
the state where you have the five shards
and five replicas
now
i'd like to start and show you
some some of the things that
that you can do with elasticsearch and
i'm just gonna tell you in advance what
i'm gonna do
uh the first is the install and if you
already got your uh
elasticsearch package untargeted you're
pretty much there um
then i wanna show you how to index the
document how to retrieve update and
delete
um
then i want to show a bit about
searching and faceting for getting uh
you know a bit of of statistics
then i want to show how to scale up the
thing that i just looked at
and
in the end i want to talk a bit about
performance and monitoring
so
okay i just have
my elasticsearch unpacked here
i wanna
do a bit of a configuration change
because i would like to
i would like to disable the multicast
discovery i talked about in a bit
because i want to be alone in my cluster
for now
and now to start elasticsearch you just
say elasticsearch i'll say minus f for
foreground
see what's going on
error thank you very much
well it's a demo it has to be an error
somewhere right
um
and this is where it listens to so
i should be able to
check if it works
yay i have my node up so to index of our
first document i will just do a put
request
to my address
let's say one index blog post so i'll
say blog
posts
is my first document
i'll come back to what these things are
in a minute
um
and then i'll put my
json document here let's say title
please work
yay
i've got my first document in and now i
just want to
talk a bit about
this bit here about what is a an index a
type an id and so on
so
so an index is
if you're familiar with lucien you have
an index is a bunch of shards and a
sharp is a leucine index
so an index will provide you with a
physical separation of your data so if
you have
uh data that you search independently
like say you search in your blog posts
and in your products and you want them
physically separate you can have
multiple indices you can also search
across
multiple indices there's no problem in
that
a type would be another level of a
container that goes within the index
and the idea is in the type you have the
definition of how your documents look
like the field uh every field in your
document is defined there and so you
would use
um
you would use
type
so
okay so you'd use
types to
to divide different
documents with different uh
schemas let's say
so if you have for example posts and
users they will have different fields
you might want to put them in different
types and finally the id is something is
a string that will
identify the document within
the type within the index
and this idea of having index type and
ids gives you the address of your
document and you can use that address to
get a document for example let's say
if we do a get request
on
blog
post
one
there's the document we can make it
pretty
prettier
and you can use the same address to uh
to update so we'll just do a post
request
one and there's the update endpoint
and then i'll say
um
i want to add
another bit of a document
i want to add a couple of tags
let's say elastic search in new york
so now the document is updated
and you can see that version is now two
it used to be one
where you used to be one
so
version is something that you can use
for concurrency control so for example
uh like we updated now
what happens uh behind the scenes when
you update is that it gets the current
version of the document it applies the
changes you want it to and then it puts
the resultant document back
and now if someone else would
or you know something would change the
version in between it will throw you an
error and say hey version has changed
and then you can retry or you can make
it automatically retry or something like
that
you can also use this address to
to delete if you want to delete a
document
you will just say
a delete request
to
but i don't really want to delete it
because i have to put it back
but anyway this is how the request would
look like and
uh this is how you can delete the whole
type
or the whole index
or everything
sorry
i'm afraid to type combinations that i'm
not aware of i
just type it like this
i don't wanna
okay i'll type hi okay i'll i'll do that
yeah
okay
so um
so right now let's do a search because
that's what it's all about right
and again you would put an address here
like where do you want to search do you
want to search in one index in multiple
index you can separate them by comma do
you want to separate search in the type
in this case i want to search in every
everywhere because
that's all i got
um and let's say i want to search and
run a query
for
i'm looking for a term
in the
in the field
tags
and my determine look i'm looking for is
new
and i'm going to take advantage of this
to make it pretty
thank you so now i got my document if
you found it even though it says new
york
and
i got my relevancy score here
and now um
you know i searched for new i got new
york because of analysis analysis is a
process that will take the string a
string like new york and break it into
tokens so just to
see how it works you can use an api
called
analyze api
so you can do something like this
give it the string
and you can see it it got me new
and york
so that's why when i search for the for
new it got it found document
now let's say that we don't want to
we don't want to
um
to to get these partial matches these
are tags we only want exact matches
so
to do that we have to change the mapping
the mapping is something that is
attached to your type so let's just see
what the mapping looks like
right so these are the the fields that
elasticsearch
uh
detected for you i have two string
fields
and
um what i want to do is to add something
in this mapping and say
stop analyzing my tags i want only exact
matches
now in order to do that
i have to first delete the mapping
which will also delete my document but
i'll put it back
okay i'll
delete my mapping and i'm going to put a
new mapping that will
tell not to analyze my tag
so the mapping will be about posts
we have the following properties
i want
tags
of type string
string is good
but i want to say when you index
not
analyzed
two three four
hopefully yes
so
now
if i do
uh if i repeat the search
you won't find me any documents because
i don't have the
go on
so
like previous we did a full request
in the last research
so i'm just
thinking i'll be using it as a database
also or is it just like
you can we can also use it for for
storing the data i think it's kind of
relates to a question that was asked
earlier about if you want to use the
search engine to also persist your data
you can um i guess it depends on the
exact use case if you if this is the
best place to store your data or not
but how are you guys
at the database
uh for example in the product that i'm
working on which is about indexing logs
we also use elasticsearch for storing
them
you're welcome
right so now
if i change my query to new york it
should work
unless i get a typo
it didn't set data
i didn't add it so that's why yeah
makes sense
okay let me add it back
so it's not because of the analysis
changes that the
previous search didn't
didn't find anything right
so
title
eggs
so now
the one that said new still doesn't
return anything
the one that says new york
should
yay
right so now let's do
let's do a tag cloud i mean i won't do
the actual tag cloud like this but i
just want to get the counts of what tags
are more popular and what aren't
what tags aren't that popular so
i'll use facets for this
so there's a facet that can just count
the terms and tell me which are the ones
that occur more often
so to do that you would just do an
ordinary search request
and if you don't specify any search
criteria i will just match everything
and i want to say my facets you can put
multiple facets here
i'm just going to have one that will be
tag cloud
that would be my name
um
and the facet will be of type terms
this will count my terms
and i want to look in the field tags
not pretty
and clear
pretty
right so
that's not very useful because we only
have one occurrence of each tag but if i
put another document
let's say
introduction
to hadoop
and
new york
and
yeah and now if i really run
the facet
you you can see that new york appears
twice
once elasticsearch ones so that should
if we have something to graph that you
will see the tech clock
what i want to say after that
right now on a scale does everyone have
elasticsearch installed
you don't
no no one okay then i'll do it
that's great okay
so first thing i want to do is delete
everything
and please do that
so we can start from clean
right
i'm going to use a graphical tool to
show you what's going on in the cluster
this tool is called
elasticsearch head
and
it shows me something like this this is
my node that is already up
i'm just
going to stop my node
and do a configuration change
to re-enable multicast so that we can
see each other easily
and also
i think it would be nice if you can put
if you can give your node a name
so that you know you can see your name
up there something like that if you
don't it's fine elasticsearch will just
make one name up for you
are you using the default cluster name
or did you yes default cluster name
so these are the only changes that
okay
so now
no it should be fun
someone's there already
but it doesn't it kind of stalls
it's the beauty of giving a demo
wait it for 30 seconds
what about now
no
i'll just do this alone if you don't
mind
i just had to restart the service
so really
mine's just coming out
yours just coming up
it depends on the box i guess
okay which one is it
thank you
okay
um right so i'll just you know will
it start for you
should we try again okay let's try again
so it may be the network it may be
anything
it still scales out of the box
well
our blog doesn't exist but you know
mr george
okay so um
let's just put an index right manually
because
i don't want to default five shards
i'm gonna say
product um
i want to remove this weird index there
first
thank you now it's
green okay so i'm just going to put an
index
with outposts this is the index
and
i want to say
in my settings
settings
that
number of shards
12. instead of the five default
what did i
stream
you don't have the same
version as i am does everyone have
let me just get back
to something i know works
um shut down notes now
are you shut it down right okay
yes usually it's a version issue when
that happens but
you know
stuff happens
okay so i'm just going to start it again
yeah
i forgot to mention that
so yeah if you have nodes running
different versions they might not know
how to communicate with each other that
might have caused the issue
so i'll just start two nodes here
and we'll pick it up from there
movies and everything where did this
come from
so what i have just one note
it's all going wrong right
well i just got mine
no no i'm just i'm
i've disabled multicast but at least i
hope i disabled it
you have to
well never mind you know i'm taking too
much of your time so um
let's just assume that we have a cluster
there
and if you want to put an index with a
custom number of shards
uh i think i've already done that but i
got my exception
so this is how it should work and then
you would have
huh
f7 f5
right i have my index with a lot of
shards and then but if you
when you create the index you kind of
have to decide on the number of shards
uh that cannot be changed afterwards uh
but what you can change is the number of
replicas and you can just change
the settings
of your existing
index
so we have a settings api here
settings
and i'm going to say number
of
replicas
i'm going to set it to zero
so you can see now that my replicas have
disappeared and you can do that while
your cluster is running so if you had if
you need more concurrency or more
availability and you add more nodes you
can just expand your uh
the number of replicas while you do that
um
okay so the last bit i'm going to talk
about is
performance and monitoring so about
performance you know
there's a lot to talk about when it
comes to performance i just want to give
you three things
uh one is about memory because
elasticsearch is quite memory hungry or
has all those buffers and caches and so
on so
it's nice to give it to give it room uh
usually a good start is to have um
half of your memory allocated to
elasticsearch and the other half you
leave it for your operating system to
cache your
your indices that you have on disk
um
then if you want to index fast the the
best thing you can do first is to use
the bulk api this api which i'll show
you in a bit allows you to send multiple
documents with one request so that saves
you a lot of network
coming and going
and the last thing about searches that
should help you is if you can use
filters when you just need a yes or no
whether whether something matches the
criteria you're searching for or not for
example
if you're searching logs you probably
want them sorted by timestamp anyway so
you don't care about relevancy if you
don't care about relevancy then filters
will be faster because
they don't calculate the score so that's
that's already faster and
because it's just a yes or no answer it
can be easily cached so you
queries will be a lot faster
and these are muffin cups i've been
pointed
but i like muffins i don't drink coffee
so i just want to show you how we can do
these three things um
the memory settings are in
where are they in the
if you if you use the star archive there
here
you can have this is the initial hip
size this is the maximum hip size and
you can tune that
if you want to
index multiple documents at one time
i'm just going to show you
how you can do that
um
i think it's post it's post here
let's say blog posts
and then i'll use the bulking point
and then the idea here is that
you
put your jsons and you separate them via
a new line
and usually have two
two jsons for every request if you have
the one will say what you want to do in
this case i want to index a new document
it can be
an update it can be a delete that will
go in here
and then you you put some more
information in this case i won't put
anything because i already have my index
there my uh my type there and if you
don't specify any id it will
generate one for you
and then a new line and then on the next
line i'll put the json with my
document
okay and then another new line and let's
index just another document
okay and finish with a new line and
this should work
so you can see it returns you an array
and it tells you for every operation
that it succeeded and all the
information like this is the id that was
generated and so on
and the last thing about filters you a
filter will look pretty much like a
query
so same search endpoint
same pretty please don't forget
but instead of a query here i'm gonna
say filter
and again i'm going to look about by the
turn
title
intro
so it matched my document you can see
here that
the score is always one because it
doesn't bother
uh calculating the score
now the last thing i want to talk about
is monitoring and you have quite a lot
of apis that will uh tell you what's
going on the one that i want to show you
is called node stats api
so if you just say
sorry
stats
and this will get you a lot of metrics
about what's going on like how much
searching have you done how much
time has spent there
same while indexing how big is your
index a lot of stuff you can add
parameters that will tell you jvm
statistics so
a lot of other metrics
if you need something visual to help you
with that
well there's obviously this one which
will let you
see
see some something
but if you want to see those metrics in
particular you can use something called
big desk
which is
again you just clone the repository you
open index.html and
then you connect your cluster
you select the node that you want to
watch
and it will start gathering metrics and
you can see here
jvm stats all the things that i've i've
talked about um
searches
and so on if you want something more
persistent we have a product that's
called uh
spm
i actually have that installed
and will
these are the points where we
started moving with the cluster nodes
and so on
you also can gather lots of metrics and
keep them for you
um
and this is pretty much it the progress
bar is full
um just just a quick look back uh
look at indexing
searching and analyzing
uh
we tried to scale out
and pretty much everything was done json
over http
and uh yeah that's pretty much it so
if you have any questions
i'll be glad to
answer like now or later
whenever
so why is elasticsearch better than
i wouldn't say that one is better than
the other
uh it's a bit of a flame war really um
well you have
some elastic search has some stuff that
solar doesn't like this thing of uh that
should have worked about you know
just adding another node by default
seeing each other and migrating shards
and everything
solar has some stuff that elasticsearch
doesn't like shard splitting for example
so
you know it depends on
exactly your use case what what works
best for you so
i would just blindly recommend one over
the other
so i was going to ask about the short
answer you said when you super sharp
size you can't change the size of that
so what happens if you add a lot of
nodes that exceed your shard's eyes
you mean the number of shards yeah
um
well what you can do
um
yeah so you have to plan that out
so you can you can just have uh
more shards you can account for future
growth uh there are also depending on
how your
use case actually looks like for example
if you have logs i keep coming back to
that because it's my thing uh if you
have logs or anytime
time series data you can have something
like uh one index per time interval
let's say one index per day
so then
every day you create a new index and
then you can decide that day how many
shards you want
and that actually has a lot of
advantages if you have time series data
because you have a hot index that would
be smaller if you index there
you know a lot of stuff
but i think you can also use
yes
there's yeah there's there are aliases
there's an alias api so if you use that
sort of uh time series of also
if you break your data into multiple
indices you can also use aliases to see
to say something like these are all my
indices and then when you run a search
if your alias is called all you would
just use all as your
as if it would be a real index and it
would search everywhere
or you can have an alias that says
latest and will point to your latest
index and when you add a new index you
just move the alias and your application
will only look at the latest index
so that that also should help
um so
the nodes um
synchronize instantly apparently um
what happens when you have nodes at
really distant locations like in a
different continent is that is that
advice
not really i mean you can have some
control over what's going on for example
you can say
that
i don't want a shard in its replica to
be on the same
continent or data center or rack or
something like that
but i'm not aware of something that
would be truly data center where within
elasticsearch
okay
all right so um
so i get how all the different nodes
find each other with the multicast and
cluster with multicast yeah that's
pretty cool i understand that what i
don't understand is once you've done
that how do clients find the cluster and
know which node to talk to
well it depends on what you use for a
client in this case if you use it over
http
you can just
communicate to any of the nodes
sorry
they're all equivalent so if you want to
yeah when you index it will redirect you
to the correct node something like that
you can also have
you can configure nodes
to not have any data so if you
have a lot of requests you can have a
node that to act as load balancer
so you will not be bothered if you keep
it with
does that answer your question
well just yeah i think i think you were
first yeah
um actually yeah forgive it if it's a
naive question
if you have a lot of updates
how is that propagated to the replicants
like is there any guarantees
for your clients um when they get the
the timelines of the data
um
yes
so when you when you index something
your the first place where your indexing
operation will go will be the primary
shard
and then
elasticsearch has a transaction log so
uh that
that will get replicated to it to all
the shards and then the shards the all
the replicas and then replicas will
index uh
the same documents
and
by default when you when you index the
the operation returns only when all the
replicas are
are done but you can also say just
you can also have a parameter which is
called async
replication or something like that where
you can just
say return only after the primary chart
index
just feedback on that
previous question
so if even if you knew that initial node
what if that node goes down
so you presumably you want to know at
least a few backup nodes
right right you can have a load balancer
or you can just it depends on the client
uh if you have there are some api for
that yes i mean
you can with a client you can say uh you
can define an array with some clients
you can define an array of nodes and
we'll just
round drop in between them or connect
one and if it doesn't work try the next
one or something like that
i just want to pull off the impression
thing i just know so
when you write to your primary insurer
it's just pretty cute to the other
replicas right
and then like what if you have updates
to a document and at the same time do a
search so will you see different results
because this update doesn't get
populated yes you will see different
results how would you handle that thing
i don't know i guess it depends
everybody you actually want to have
okay so maybe a successful ride is when
you get get get replica
yes um
you what you can do is when you search
you can say preference and tell it where
you want which charge you want to hit
first you can
always prefer the primary chart and that
will give you the latest data
but then replicas will only be for
backup they won't
so it's always trade-off i guess
in terms of memory uh i don't understand
it would depend on the data that is
being indexed and searched
on typical linux configuration let's say
server
what's your experience
elaborate memory
through configuration
so the question was
okay the the memory requirements depend
on the configuration but what um
what would be the typical requirement
right
i don't know it depends so much on not
only how much data you have but also how
you query it so for example if you if
you do very expensive statistics
uh it will you will load a lot of data
in memory so you can compute it faster
it's called a field cache and that is
you know can get really big even if you
have if you don't have that much data so
it really depends a lot on how to use
how you use it um
i don't know if you have something like
uh
i can tell you from my experience with
logs if that helps
so
in my experience if you have something
like um
i don't know
50 million of a typical log typical i
know 250 byte log
you will use
one gigabyte of memory or something like
that
it depends so much on what you actually
do
are there clients that can all discover
all the nodes
given just one
node uh yeah the java client can do that
it will join the cluster as if it would
be a node when it won't
um
uh you won't host any data
and then you will be aware of what's
going on because it will retrieve all
the updates from the cluster state
with something like uh head plugin would
it see
no the head plugin works through http so
you have to point it to know that
actually works and then you will get
everything
uh how does it scale with when you start
adding millions of documents in an index
and
have things like engramming to a single
character or document if at all
well i haven't i didn't have problems
with scaling elasticsearch so i guess
the answer is well
but i don't know really
it depends so you haven't noticed
anything sorry you haven't noticed any
issues when you played
i can answer this one i mean that
particular thing is completely sort of
your sea level thing so if you know how
solar hand was it nice it is going
pretty much the same way as far as that
particular use case
because elasticsearch itself doesn't
really do anything and then
use the same analyzers to chop up
you know
the input into inverse
uh in terms of low level we've seen
stuff like uh direct the various
directory implementations codecs and
analyzers and filters
is that the same as we're seeing in
solar a lot of it yes
are there any uh
proprietary ones that come with
elasticsearch um
or is it one
no because it's totally source so okay
yeah
so all right
it's great again so does it extend
the basic functionality in any way or it
just does yes for example this facets
that i showed you is is its own
implementation and
there is going to be a new version
really soon actually the beta there's a
beta already available version 1.0 this
one that i used was 0.90
and that has something that's called
aggregations
and it allows you to do a lot more
statistics that you can currently do
with facets and it's just an example so
what's the underlying
implementation here
what's the version
it's for uh it's actually i think the
latest or just
they usually keep up
i um during the auto discovery yes demo
you made mention of everybody needs to
be on the scene version yes which
reminded me to ask about version
management
as the next version comes out what's the
typical pattern for going from one
version to the next
oh
as in you set up a replica oh sorry you
set up a
redundant one
yeah that would be an option
yes that would be an option or just it
depends on how much
availability you want if you can afford
to just shut down the cluster upgrade
everything and bring it back up
then that that will work or you can just
i don't know
have yeah have a new cluster point
point your clients to it and just switch
or something like that
so no notion just yet of like a rolling
virtual object no no
not yet
so when there's a version update do we
need to re-index everything no you don't
you don't even if it's a major uh new
scene for example if when you you used
uh lucien 3.6 i think it was before and
then it migrated to four
uh
no it just upgraded uh everything
i think we should wrap up but um yeah i
want to point out uh one thing uh there
will be a talk on elasticsearch as it's
used at tumblr either next
month's meetup or the one after that i'm
not sure anymore so if you're interested
in elasticsearch
you know check out the meetup site and
maybe
they are using a pretty large scale
obviously over there so they'll be you
know some juicy stuff i imagine from
there there's search the main search
guys will be giving the call
and you can also grab me here and ask me
questions
okay thank you